みなさん、ここでドガンし
ました。スポンサー付きのビデオである今日のビデオでは、
アプについて話します。日本の大学であるアジアパシフィック大学で作りましょう。
ごく最近まで
、このビデオを作ることにした主な理由は
、この
ビデオで
話しているのは、高校生のときに知りたかったことであり、
それが意味するのは、私が在籍して
いた
ときだったからです。 高校
日本に興味
があった
ので、留学でも長期でも
日本に行きたいと思っていたのですが、どういうわけか日本に
行きたいと思っていました。
私のアメリカの高校
から州の大学に直接アメリカの
大学
は、英語の教師として日本に戻って卒業した後、その4年間のうちの1年間の
留学のようなものかもしれません。
なぜなら、それがワシントン州のレドモンド高校からワシントン大学に行く唯一の選択肢だと思ったからです。
東京のコ大学で1年間
留学しました。州に戻り、
学位を取得してから日本に戻りました。 英語の先生として、
それが唯一の方法だと思っていました。
アメリカの高校から日本の
大学に直接行くことができると知っ
ていたら、それは私がした
ことです。 この種の代替軌道を提供し
ているのは、アプーであろうと日本
の他のいくつかの
学校であろうと、
私がしたであろうオプションだったので
、
この情報を知りたいと思う人が少なくとも一握りはいると思い
ます だから
私はあなたがapuにどのように適用できるかについて話
します
apuは学生生活のようなものですそして
私が前もって強調する価値があると思う他のことの1つは大学
に行くほうがしばしばはるかに安いということです
日本
はアメリカよりも多様性があるので
、ビデオで詳しく説明し
ますが、キャンパス自体について話すだけで始められるかもしれません。apu
は、学生の体の大きさである約6000人の学生がいる学校です。
繰り返しになります
が、私が住んでいる小さな都市は
約12億5300万
人で、大学の県であるオイタケンにある
ので、日本の
4つの主要な島の最南西部は
クールなものの1つです。
大学自体の観点から見たapuについて
は、そもそも
学校が2000年4月1日に設立されたのはかなり新しいことです。
それと
、私が東京に行った大学のよう
に、キャンパスは
真新しく、東京に行ったキャンパスのように、キャンパスはビジネス
の真ん中にあるようなものでした。
非常に小さく、
いわばビジネス街を歩いて
いるような感覚で、キャンパス内は
舗装されたコンクリートのような中庭のようですが、
apuは他のどの大学よりもはるかに開放的です。
日本
とキャンパスで見
たキャンパスの実際の様子をBロールで紹介しますが
、この山の頂上にある
ので、
ベップを見下ろすことができ、この
ゴージャスな美しいキャンパスのようです。 繰り返しになりますが、私
はapuで
働いていましたが、そこで働くことで本当に楽しかったことの1つ
は、昼休みに行くときなど
、キャンパス内を歩き回るのが楽しいこと
です。これも環境が
とても美しいからです。
とても開放的で、
窮屈ではないので
、最初の物理的な学校自体
はとても素敵で、
キャンパスには他のものの1つである巨大な寮があります。
おそらく東京の大学や
日本の他のほとんどの大学と比較する価値があると思いますが
、これは少し変わっていますが
、私は東京
の大学から
約30分または45分
離れた大学の寮に住んでいました
が
、apuには
繁華街の寮
も何と言いますか。でも、1年生の留学生は皆、山の頂上にあるキャンパスに
ある寮の中で、外国人の
学生で
も場所を確保できると
思います。
山の頂上
ここにもう少しb-rollを入れますが
、これらの寮の部屋のいくつかからの眺めのよう
に素晴らしいので
、キャンパス自体は本当に
素晴らしい場所であり
、日本の他のほとんどの大学と比較
して とにかく私が見たものは
本当にそれ自身のクラスにあるので
、おそらくかなり良い物理的なキャンパスの観点から、
私は大学
の目的のようなものについて話し始めると
思います 学生の体のような構造と
2つの大学
、そしてまた
、apuでどのような教育を受けることができる
かということ
は、いわばこのビデオの肉の
ようなものだと思うので、
apuは日本の他のすべての大学とは異なります。
また
、世界のどこにいても、ほとんどの大学
は、留学したときの学生の体は
日本人
と
外国人の半分
でした。正確な数は覚えていませ
んが、 圧倒的に日本人
で、
キャンパスにいる外国人学生の圧倒的多数は、私のような
留学先で、
大学
に1年間通う学生でしたが、残念ながら
、このような状況で起こるの
は、
外国人、そして残りの
学生
は日本人ですが、実際に
は
その小さなバブルから抜け出すのは少し難しくなり、学生の
体にとっては 本当に
重なるのはちょっと些細なことのように聞こえますが
、実際には
その障壁を破るのは少し難しいです。文字通り
、私がいたキャンパス
のカフェテリアには
、留学生の小さなグループのように
、そしてそこに
他のみんなは基本的に
日本人で、
もちろん何らかの交流を知っているでしょう
が、他の種類の主要なことの1つは、
ほとんどすべての交換留学生が
日本語を勉強するためにそこにいるので、実際に
はコミュニケーションが取れないということです
ほとんどの留学生とほとんど
の留学生
は流暢な日本語しか話せないので、そこにも
コミュニケーションの障壁
があります。そのよう
な状況に基づい
て、2つのグループ
がそのままの形でそれぞれの形をとるのは自然なことです。 グループは
多かれ少なかれそのバブルの中にとどまります
今apuはこれとは根本的に異なり
ます つまり、学生の体は
学部生な
ので、4年間在籍している普通の学生
は留学生なので
、
アメリカの高校
を卒業して直接日本の
大学に行って受けた私のようなアメリカ人の学生のようになります。
大学教育で
は、apuの学生の半数が
そのカテゴリーに分類されます。彼らは必ずしもアメリカ人ではありません。
先ほど話したように、世界中から来ていますが
、日本人学生と
外国人学生の両方がそこにいるからです。
１年生から
寮に同居していることもあり
、アプにはたくさんのコースが設けられ
ており、１年生は学生
同士の交流を余儀なくされて
いる
ので、
よく典型的な大学で以前に話さ
れたのは、それが州にあるのか、それとも日本
にあるのか、それはapuには完全に存在せず、
実際には
日本人学生、そして留学生を代表して、
もう1つ簡単に触れておきたいの
は、
前の例で
、交換留学生全員がバブルの中にいる様子について話しましたが、
実際に見たのです。 当時の私
の大学だったワシントン大学でも同じ
ことが起こっているので
、交換
留学生は全員日本からやって来
て、日本の
交換留学生
バブルグループと50〜100
人の留学生がほとんどのようになります。
お互いに話し合って
そのグループにとどまり、
apはその点で根本的に異なっていました
。あなたは最初の年からapuで出会ったすべての人から本当にしっかりしたミックスを得ることができます。
学生たち
私はその経験からの前向きな思い出しか持っていない
ので
、いくつかの逸話をあげます本当の
クイック
jpは明らかに私が知っている人の一人です
w apuからですが、たぶん
私が昼食をとった2人の人は、
名前を付けることができませんでしたが
、1人はケニア出身で、1人は
ウガンダ出身だったので、多くの場合、私
はケニア出身のこの男です。 ウガンダ
、それから
私、アメリカ人、そして多分2人の
日本人スタッフか何か
、そして私たちは皆、
国際的な食べ物を提供し
、
ハラルフードや
他の制限された食事のようなたくさんのオプションがあるキャンパスのカフェテリアに行きます
が、私たちは行きます そこにいると
、私たち全員が
英語で話すか、
完全に日本語で話すか、または
その2つの組み合わせを話すこと
になります。次に、隣のテーブル
では
、韓国人学生、中国人学生
、そして
おそらく ウガンダですが、
みんな日本語で話している
ので、とても印象的でしたので、もう一つの
逸話が
うまく表現され
ていると思います。
apu apmのリクルーターだったので、仕事でやったことの1つは、
これらの国に行くときは、主にアジア東アジア南東アジアを回るということです。
私がこれをしたとき、私は
これらの都市にいるapuの卒業生とも会いましたが、
私
はこれらのプレゼンテーションを行い、
その後、
この卒業生のグループ
と夕食に出かけました。 私は多分中国人の
男マレーシア人の男ウズベキスタン
の男アフリカの男ケニアやウガンダを知ってい
ますどこにいても前に話しましたが
、それは
あなたが日本ではない完全に外国の私たち
全員です
が、私たちは 座って
いると、中華料理のように食事をしたり
、日本語で話したりするのを知っているかもしれません。
これもまた、とてもユニークな
思い出に残る体験
でした。
アポでの日常生活の中で、4月
の学生の半数は日本人で、
半数は留学生であることがわかりました
。これ
は、私の間に出会った人がたくさんいるので、強調する重要なポイントだと思います。
私の以前の
apuでの仕事や、以前の自分のような人々は、
留学プログラムを経ていない限り、日本の大学に出願できないという印象を受けています。
これはまったく真実ではなく
、2種類あります。 外国人留学生としてapuを適用しやすくする
差別化要因を区別するのは本当に大きなことです。
最初の理由は、apuには2つの
登録期間がある
ため、4月に学校を始めるほとんどの日本の大学とは異なり
apuに
は2つの登録があるということです。 期間とそれ
はあなたが
受け入れられた場合あなたが9月に学校を始めることができるようにあなたが学校に
申し込むことができることを意味します
それはええとほとんどの
西部のええと高等教育機関
と完全に一致します それから、またはあなたがすでに日本に住んでいて
、多分あなたが
日本の学校を卒業したなら、あなたは
4月の入学を申請することができますので、あなたは
いつでも
本当に本当に
重要な他のこと、そして
おそらくあなたたちのほとんどが疑問に思っていることを申請することができます
あなたが高校にいる場合、私は
apuに申し込むために日本語を話さなければなりません、
そしてこれに対する答えは
あなたが完全に英語でapuに申し込むことができません、
または完全に日本語で
あなたはで流暢でなければなりません
apuに申し込むために1つの言語を勉強
する必要はありませんあなたはあなたの申し込みにプラスになる日本語を知っていれば日本語を知る必要はありません
があなたはapuと多くの学生に申し込んで受け入れられることができます
これは
、日本語をまったく知らなくても
、高校の最終学年でapu
に申し込む
ことができます。これは、アメリカの大学に申し込むのと同じように、apuに
成績
を送り、なぜあなたがintereであるかについてのエッセイを送ります。
毎年apuに入学する外国
人学生の圧倒的多数は
英語で応募し、日本語をほとんどまたはまったく話せませ
ん。
その後
、apuには必須の語学コースがあり
ます。
1年目と2年目に
本当に
集中的な日本語教育
を受けた後、日本人学生がこれらのコース
を通じて英語教育と同じことを経験するような学生のために、
基本的に
各
グループの両方で日本人学生日本人
学生団体、そして
留学生団体
は反対の言語
を学び、大学での4年間の終わりまでに
、日本語で就職できなければ、通常は少なくとも会話が
流暢になります。 この
後のキャリアの見通しのように
大丈夫
ですので、多くの人が心配していると確信しているので、コストについて話しましょう
apu
で4年間、あるいは1
年間apuで勉強するのはどれほど費用がかかるか、費用の内訳を見ると、それはどのように見える
かということです。 アメリカの大学で
高等教育を受けたい
ので、apuで1年間
の簡単な内訳の授業自体
をやってみましょう。
私たちのドルで言えば、通貨の為替レートにもよりますが、
約
1万3500ドルから1万4千ドルです。
現在、
日本は明らかにできるだけ多くの
留学生
を日本に留学させようとしているので、
実際には
、アプに来る留学生のために特別に提供されるたくさんの奨学金があり
ます。
これは、すべての学生がすべてではないため、逸話です。
apuの留学生は確かに
奨学金を持っていますが、
私がapuで親しくなった留学生のほとんどは
ある種のtuitiを持っていました 削減
奨学金については、
これらの奨学金
は30％から100％までどこにでも
行きます。つまり、運が良ければ
、50の削減のようになり、約7を費やしているとし
ましょう。
epo now apuでの年間授業料千ドル
は、私が支払った
東京のような場所よりもはるかに安い住む場所である九州大田県に再びあります。
私が寮で毎月約750の家賃だったと思います。
えーと大学に留学していた時はキャンパス外に泊まりまし
たが、インターネットに住んでいたアパートのような場所をベップで見つけることができます。
他の
ユーティリティはすべて別だったと思いますが
、300年くらいでした。 今月
は東京の同じような場所に住むのにかかる費用の半分以下
で、また学生寮に住むこともでき
ます。私は彼女のビデオに価格を入れると信じています。
eしかし、それも
非常に合理的であるため、授業料の生活費
を考慮に入れてすべての費用を考慮
する
と
、アメリカ人
の場合、健康保険の費用は
実際には
大幅に安くなる可能性があります
州に戻るよりも日本の大学に行くことbep
は、そもそもapuに住むのに安い場所です。
確か
に、
州に
あるすべての私立学校と比較して、授業料は比較的安いです。たくさんの奨学金が
あります。 留学生
にとっては、学内でも学外で
も、学費でパートタイムの仕事をすることができます。これは、学費の
コンビニエンスストアに行くときに出会う学生の多く
が実際にいることを補うためです。
apuの学生は、
apuと見なされるすべてのもの
が、
おそらく従来の西洋の同等物よりも大幅に安くなる
可能性があります。 高校卒業後
すぐに適切な日本の大学に行き、
日本人でなくても
、物理的なキャンパスの種類について話し、
いくつかの写真を見たことがあります
。apuでの教育自体がどのようなものかについて話しましょう。
私がここで強調したいこと、そして
私が過去の仕事でいつも
人々にそれを説明した方法
は、apuは
いくつかの
ことには本当に良いが他のことには特に良くないということですそして
それが意味するのは
そこにあるということです apuにある2つの大学で、
2つの研究分野があります。1つはビジネス
で、もう1つは社会科学
です。これらの各大学には
、社会科学の中で今すぐ画面に表示するサブ集中の4つの集中
があります。
国際関係、そして
観光
、そしてビジネススクールの中
には明らかに
あなたが受講できるより伝統的なビジネスコースがありますが、
apuは
これらの2つのことで本当に得意ですそしてそれ
は持っています 適切な認定です
が、プログラミングやロボティクスの学位を取得したい場合、
または
明らかに英文学の
ようなものを取得したい場合、またはそのようなものはあなたのための学校ではありませ
んこれらの2つの科目に興味がある場合は素晴らしい学校ですこれらの2つの大学
これら どちらかというと2つの分野です
が、他のことには向いていないので
、
前もって知っておくのが一番
です。多く
の人がこの点を
特に興味深い
と思う他の本当に興味深いことは、  apu
だから私が語学コースと言うとき、私はあなたがそれらのコースの外であなたの日本のクラスに
行く
ようにあなたがそのクラスに行って言語を勉強するコースのようなことを意味
します
つまり
、英語でapuに申し込む場合は、英語が基本
言語であり、
受け入れられて学校に通うときに日本語があまりわからない場合は、
それが意味します。 日本人が
十分に高いレベル
になったら
、観光観光101のクラスなど、実際に通常の集中クラスをもう一度受講する
ことができます。たとえば
、英語または日本語でそのクラスを
受講できるので、それは別の種類の本当に区別できる要素だと思います。
apuや他の多くの大学がついに
就職の機会についてお話ししたい
と思います。これ
も非常に重要なトピックだ
と思います。なぜなら、ほとんどの人は、日本で就職
する唯一の方法だという印象を受けている
からです。 日本
は長期的に
は私がやったことをすることであり、
それはアメリカの大学や外国の大学を卒業してから
日本で
英語の先生になる
ことです。
途中で翻訳者になるかもしれませんが
、実際にはそうではないにもかかわらず、多くの人が英語の先生になりたいと確信しています。
今、英語を教えることに熱心に取り組んでいるapuのすごいところ
は、
留学生がたくさんいて
、英語や他の言語を話すことができる日本人学生もたくさん
いるので、毎年
文字通り何百もの日本企業
が
直接apuに来るということです。
学生を募集し
ている
apuキャンパスに行くと、日本で仕事を見つけるための求職プロセスが、日本
国外に住んでいる場合よりもはるかに簡単にナビゲートできるようになります。そのため
、apuとキャリアオフィスがあります。
日本の企業に
応募する際の履歴書の書き方など、面接の
際のビジネスエチケットのコツ
を教えてくれます。
また、企業は
学生がいることを知っているので、直接apuに来ます。
apu
を卒業すると、その特定の会社で働くために必要なスキルセット
が得られます。
彼が観光を勉強
し、cuoco観光局で働くことになった
apuからのnt
私は
google japanで働くことになった別の学生を知っていました、そして私は
前のビデオにいた別の学生を知っていました、
しかし私はここで名前を挙げません
彼は結局 日本のビデオゲーム会社で働いている
ので
、あなたの履歴書を多くの人に送って、あなたが
何をしているのか本当にわからず
、アメリカ人のように盲目的にそれを経験するという、この気が遠くなるような本当に大きな頭痛の種のプロセスをやろうとするのではありません
アメリカに住んでいると、日本の会社に応募しようとしている、
またはもう一度その英語の
仕事
をすることができます。apuシステムを使用
する
と、会社を直接apuに招待し
、そこから
、あなたが確信している英語の教育の仕事ではなく、直接日本の会社に行くことができます。
あなたが
興味を持って
いたが、実際には
このビデオで強調したい最後のポイントではなかったの
は、apuを通過
することはたくさんの まだ
日本に
いなかったら、特にapuでうまくいっていなければ、日本での潜在的なキャリアの機会は開かれませ
ん。
これ
は、キャンパスでの募集apuの多く
が特に強力であるためです。これ
も、学生の体の半分が
国際的で
あり、 このビット
をいくつかの数字で終わらせようと思いますが
、一般的に就職率は
非常に高い
ので、私は国内にいた
ので正確には思い出せませんので、留学生の世話をし
ますが、 今すぐ画面に数字を残しておく
と
、
留学生の何パーセント
が
日本企業に就職
するのか、そして何
が日本国外の企業に就職するのかが
わかります。 ここに置いておきますので、
今では誰もがapuが何であるかについてかなり良い考えを持っていると思い
ます。
このビデオで伝えたい主な
ことは、アメリカ人または非日本人から直接行くことができるということです。
日本の高校
から大学までの
年間
は
、州や
どこにいて
も、
最終年度に仕事を探しているときに卒業した後よりもはるかに安い価格で過ごすことがよくあります。
この特定の
別の軌道をたどれば、日本でたくさんのユニークな仕事の機会があなたを待っています。
私が最後に言及したいのは
、おそらくあなたが
すでに大学の外にいるのなら、
japanまたはおそらくjapaninside
で、あなたはこのビデオを聞いて
いて、面白そうだと思いました。
私がそこに行っていたらよかったのに
、apuには転校の
機会もあるので
、すでにフルタイムの学生である場合はそこから行くことができます。
別の大学
をapuに編入して、他のすべてのメリットを享受することに加えて、大学の
最後の2、3、2、1年のために追加のお金を節約できるかもしれません。
私
がこのビデオで話したことは
大丈夫です私は基本的
にこのビデオのためにカバーしたかったすべてだと思い
ます私はapの
ウェブサイトといくつかの連絡先情報のように以下のリンクを残します
が、このビデオが有用
でおそらく目を見張るものになることを願っています このビデオ
を後援してくれたapuにもう一度感謝します。
またすぐに
皆さんとお話しします。